a talk show host in the role of a cat an
NBA legend is a dancing gamer these
South Park cameos may have slipped You
by but they feature some of the most
legendary names in the entertainment
industry
George Clooney has been many things in
his long and illustrious Hollywood
career including actor director Oscar
winner and two-time sexiest man alive
but he was also one of Trey Parker and
Matt Stone's earliest fans according to
far out magazine Clooney enjoyed the
Duo's 1995 short film The Spirit of
Christmas so much that he made hundreds
of VHS copies to distribute among his
famous Pals as a tip of the cap to
Clooney's early support for their
careers Parker and stone gave Clooney a
role in one of their earliest South Park
episodes Clooney at the peak of his 90s
stardom and fresh off his turn as Batman
and the poorly received Batman and Robin
accepted a small part in season 1
episode 4. in the episode Clooney
provides the vocals for Sparky Stan's
new dog who his friends believe is gay
it's a very small role and one which
consists of no dialogue just a series of
barks sniffs growls and other related
dog noises it's easy to forget about
this early Cameo and even many hardcore
fans probably don't know that Sparky was
played by one of the biggest names in
Hollywood this wasn't the last
collaboration between Clooney and the
South Park creators he returned to voice
Dr guash in the feature film South Park
bigger longer and uncut son I have some
bad news we accidentally replaced your
heart with a baked potato you have about
three seconds to live
another Cameo that features not a single
line of actual dialogue comes to us from
season 1 episode 13. in which Cartman's
long-suffering and perpetually Hungry
Cat Mr Kitty is voiced by comedian and
late night host Jay Leno the episode was
produced several years into Leno's
tenure as the host of The Tonight Show
on NBC this vocal performance has Leno
showing off his range of meows and
hisses as he attempts to win the
sympathies and dinner scraps of Eric
Cartman while Mr Kitty appears in
numerous episodes of South Park Leno is
only credited as the voice of the
precocious feline on this singular
occasion
no kitty this is my corned beef cabbage
okay
Leno's short tenure as Mr Kitty wasn't
his first collaboration with stone and
Parker and it wouldn't be his last
months earlier The Tonight Show aired an
animated segment in which Leno spoke to
the class at South Park Elementary
afterwards Leno would return to South
Park to play himself in season 2 episode
7 having this Crabtree on his show to
promote her screaming comedy Act
with a career spanning seven decades
Henry Winkler is best known for his
roles as Arthur Fonzarelli on the 70s
sitcom Happy Days and Gene Cousineau on
the HBO dark comedy Barry thanks to the
Staggering number of film and television
credits to his name the comedy icon has
probably guest starred in something
you've seen without you even knowing it
South Park fans probably wouldn't have
recognized Winkler's voice in season 2
episode 7 unless they stuck around for
the credits in this quasi-clipse show
the boys are stuck on a school bus
teetering over the edge of a cliff after
bus driver Miss Crabtree takes an
ill-advised detour up a mountain on a
snowy day when she leaves to get help
she tells the kids not to leave the bus
lest they get gobbled up by the
kid-eating monster several of the bus's
occupants believe it to be a clever ruse
designed to keep them from wandering off
but when one Brave lad decides to make a
run for it they find out that the
monster is all too real as the
disobedient boy is gobbled up by a
fearsome black
The Roaring and chomping and teeth
gnashing were all delivered with a plum
by The Fawns himself it's yet another
high-profile South Park Cameo that
features no lines of dialogue funnily
enough Winkler's iconic Happy Days
character makes an appearance in a
reference to the infamous Jumping the
Shark episode but the voice of Fonzi is
provided by Parker rather than the man
himself easily one of the most
star-studded episodes in the show's
History season 2 episode 14 sees the
supporting character Chef sued by
capitalist records after asserting that
Alanis Morissette cribbed her new hit
stinky britches from a demo he made
years earlier after losing the court
case thanks to Johnny Cochran's
excellent implementation of the
Chewbacca defense Chef is ordered to pay
the label 2 million dollars or wind up
in jail for four years luckily Chef has
some very famous friends willing and
able to put on a massive benefit concert
to raise the money he needs to stay out
of the slammer the boys round up all his
old buddies from Ozzy Osbourne to Primus
to play the show the most notable Cameo
though is by five-time Grammy Award
winner Sir Elton John this fictionalized
version of the Crocodile rock singer
owes his lyrical Brilliance and
flamboyant wardrobe to South Park
Elementary's musical lunch server if he
wasn't for Chef I would never have had a
career in music so will you buy some of
our candy bars to help him out yes of
course I'll buy three crispy yum yums
Sir John does more than just buy some
snacks he shows up to support his old
friend and even performs an original
song that Stan wrote for his girlfriend
Wendy
George Clooney wasn't the only big name
actor to get into South Park in the
1990s according to the Huffington Post
Jennifer Aniston was also an early
adopter having been introduced to the
show by her future husband Brad Pitt
Aniston who at the time was five seasons
into her star-making performances Rachel
Green on the hugely popular sitcom
Friends got the opportunity to meet the
men behind the madness when she lent her
voice to the season 3 premiere episode
rainforest schmaine Forest Aniston plays
Miss Stevens the director of a charity
choir that recruits Elementary aged boys
and girls for a save the rainforest
concert in Costa Rica however due to a
series of unforeseen events upon the
choir's arrival in the Central American
Nation Miss Stevens quickly changes her
tune changing the theme of the concert
from save the rainforest to stop the
rainforest on the season 3 DVD
commentary the South Park creators
revealed that Aniston was very nervous
when recording her lines as she was
relatively inexperienced with voice over
work at the time once again got over her
initial Jitters however she turned in a
truly hilarious performance
hey Boris do you go right ahead and plow
down this whole thing that swell Richard
Belzer isn't a cop but he played one on
TV for 23 years since first appearing on
homicide life on the street in 1993
Belzer played his iconic law man John
Munch on 10 different programs including
Law and Order The X-Files and even
Arrested Development that's why it's so
funny to see Belzer break bad in the
first episode of South Park season 4.
perhaps in need of a break from
investigating New York's most heinous
crimes Belzer decided to return to his
comedic roots and flex the old funny
bone when he took on the role of loogie
a Don Corleone type in the body of a
fifth grader loogie runs a fake Tooth
Fairy racquet in central Colorado in an
effort to make some extra cash when the
boys start their own version of the scam
they run afoul of Lucy's crew and find
themselves the subjects of a missing
teeth investigation by the American
Dental Association I want those softball
kids dead I want their families dead I
want their houses burned to the ground
oh hi there mister my mommy daddy you're
out front if you need them
counterculture Comedians and Mary Jane
enthusiasts Cheech Marin and Tommy Chong
are no strangers to pushing boundaries
their debut film Up in Smoke was the
progenitor of the stoner buddy comedy
when it was released in 1978 after
parting ways to pursue other projects in
the mid-80s their appearance in South
Park season 4 episode 6 was something of
a creative reunion for the pair Marin
and Chong play a pair of roles
reminiscent of their Stoner characters
of the 70s and 80s their two employees
had misinformation's new age shop a
holistic healing boondoggle that
attracts the patronage of many of the
South Park Townsville when Kyle finds
himself with a kidney infection he's
taken to the new age shop where Carlos
and chief Hawk natural remedies that
unsurprisingly do very little to repair
his renal function after the town finds
out the truth about misinformation and
her store they attack her on the spot
and run her employees out of town
eight-time NBA All-Star and Hall of Fame
Center Yao Ming is obviously best known
for his eight Seasons with the Houston
Rockets the seven foot six big man
averaged 9.2 rebounds and 19 points per
game during his illustrious career Ming
was inducted into the Basketball Hall of
Fame in 2016 alongside another famous
center with acting credits Shaquille
O'Neal in 2004 10 days before the first
game of the Western Conference first
round Series against the Los Angeles
Lakers Yao Ming lent his vocal talents
to Parker and stone for South Park
season 8 episode 4. in the episode which
sees the boy's challenge to a dance
competition by a crew from Orange County
Ming provides the voice of Yao a local
Dance Dance Revolution wizard who holds
the record on the machine at the local
arcade he refuses to dance without a
computer telling him what to do
believing it to be a stupid Pastime
otherwise thankfully Yao eventually
agrees to participate and South Park
wins the competition by default after
Butters accidentally crushes the
opposing team under a rafter of Lights
as one of those actors that you've seen
one time in that one thing Diedrich
Bader has over 200 acting credits and is
no stranger to comedic voice over work
you've heard his voice on everything
from The Simpsons to Harley Quinn and
you might recognize him as Bill Erickson
on Veep or more recently as Tony unlucky
Hank in season 9 episode 5 of South Park
Vader provided the voice for Randy
Marsh's Little League trash talking
adversary known only as BatDad this
overweight and over enthusiastic father
of the Denver Little League team's
second baseman wears a cowling cape and
frighteningly little else to every game
come on Denver get the lead out do not
cross the back dead
geez I really wish this guy would shut
up the over-the-top performance
culminates in a knock down drag out
brawl with Randy at Coors Field during
the Colorado Little League Championship
thanks to encouragement from Stan and
his friends Randy wins the fight
disqualifying South Park from the game
and proving that he's truly the best
around
when long-standing cast member Isaac
Hayes took Umbridge with Parker and
Stone's depiction of Scientology in the
season 9 episode Trapped in the Closet
the character of Chef was written off
the show but it didn't take long for him
to return to town in the season 10
premiere Chef returns to South Park with
vocals cobbled together from old
recordings having traveled the world
with the Super Adventure Club however
something is rotten in the state of
Colorado as the boys realize that their
friend has been brainwashed by the
nefarious Cult of adventurers at the end
of the episode Chef is struck by
lightning and Falls seemingly to his
death however his fellow super
adventurers resurrect his body in a
Darth vader-style costume turning him
into Darth Chef this version of the
character is played by British voice
acting icon and master impressionist
Peter sarahfinowich Sarah finowicz
doesn't have much to say in this role
but what few lines he has he Nails a
perfect cross between the deep bass
voices of Isaac Hayes and James Earl
Jones this Cameo is brief but
undoubtedly remember
Josh gadd had already worked with Parker
and stone when he was cast in South Park
season 21 episode 5. six years earlier
Gad was the first person to take on the
role of Elder Cunningham and Parker and
Stone's hit Broadway musical The Book of
Mormon Gad was nominated for a Tony
Award for his performance and the show
won a total of nine trophies including
best musical at the 2011 awards ceremony
in South Park Gad plays the role of
Marcus Preston a kid traumatized by the
overdose deaths of several costumed
birthday party characters he attempts to
uncover the source of the drugs
responsible and discovers that a
resident of a local nursing home has
been hiding illicit substances inside
throw pillows and distributing them to
the residents of the town there is an
epidemic in our community sir some of us
actually can't confront the problem no
damn it what did you find after taking
down the elderly Kingpin responsible
with the help of Stan and his
grandfather Marcus dedicates his life to
stopping the opiate crisis on a much
larger scale
thank you